oh thank you very much
okay but wait a lot to get to today joe
biden
first trip overseas he is at this hour
in england he has embarked on his
sorry about the last guy tour
uh he's gonna meet
with the g7 people he like did you say
this he landed the airport and a cicada
landed on him and i can't i can't even
q anon thinks this is very significant
no seriously because you know they're
all about the
letter q and it's the 17th letter of the
alphabet
and the cicadas come out every 17 years
and it landed on biden so
[Music]
[Applause]
the cicadas put out a statement today
they said could you not drag us into
this [ __ ] please
we're just cicadas
[Applause]
but uh sunday biden is going to go to
windsor castle to meet with the
queen the newly widowed queen he was
going to
express his condolences for her losing
prince philip and she's going to express
her condolences
for joe losing joe manchin
this joe mansion boy have you been
reading about him
for a democrat he is the most powerful
republican in the senate i tell you this
guy
he he has blocked every
big thing that the democrats want to do
the voting rights
legislation the january 6 commission
even infrastructure
that's [ __ ] dead now the talks broke
down they said because of i love this
irreconcilable differences
which sounds to me like a marriage
or a divorce which is appropriate
considering next year they may get the
house
but democrats did win one this week the
the keystone pipeline you're familiar
that's dead now
um and you seem excited about that
uh no no i'm yeah it's probably not good
but
don't be too happy because shutting it
down will cost thousands of jobs
mostly of hackers in moscow who are
going to ransom it for bitcoin
but they are jobs
also speaking of ways we found out this
week that not we didn't find out we've
known this but it's worse than ever
billionaires and i'm talking about the
top
of the top of the to the richest of the
brits
don't pay any taxes and this is the kind
of stuff that really pisses people off
uh
jeff bezos this morning was walking down
his driveway and he found out
somebody keyed his rocket
you know people are pissed yeah he's
uh oh you know he's uh
he's got a rocket company i mean you
gotta if you got that kind of money you
gotta have a rocket company
the schmuck doesn't have a rocket
company he's got one muscle
this is named blue origin and it's going
to make its first
manned manned first space flight
next month this is their maiden voyage
and jeff bezos is going to be on the
rocket
i'm telling you wouldn't you if you had
that kind of money
let someone else in the company go up
first wouldn't it
like hey
you know what
i'm bob in the warehouse how'd you like
to drive in space
you see if it works you know i'll go up
next
but i know what's going to happen now
amazon is going to completely take up
her space and they're going to
put all the mom and pop astronauts out
of business
but we but look we got we've got
problems here on earth
did you see uh poor kamalaharas biden
dumped the border problem in her lap you
know so she was getting testy with
reporters this week because they're like
you're not fixing the border crisis
well a little perspective mike pence
his biggest accomplishment was not being
hung by his own people
so as vice presidents go
you